welcome to this video and playing brulor
from Portugal I guess he'll probably
Kings Indian or modern defense let's see
I kept playing a style of the modern c6
mmmm now let's see many ways o H voice a
bit early yeah I had forgotten that
Knight f6 of course is still still a
possibility ok I nothing nothing
dramatic but not what i wanted to want
it to have
yeah I select this idea to play h5 gain
this space on the Kings side yeah hmm
it's always tough to decide should you
play before in this position maybe
thought so loosening up the Queen side
of it there are things i already have
played each floor so not so sure that
short castling is coming on time how to
play this f3 and g3 does this type of
setup night c4 I can do that b5 for only
looks good i can play night 85 i came so
i probably how to play this without a 3g
five maybe maybe maybe Bishop g5 be five
still night 85 so maybe continue
normally
yeah so lots o clear what my kingdom
will be doing
of course I don't want to play Bishop
age six or something but how do I play
but that's an unexpected set up really
Bishop won't be some mmm not sure what
he's trying to do maybe sacrifice on one
knee form or something here I feel
castling should be okay with the bishop
on b7
mmm yeah f5 I can still do that at the
undermind smile my d5 pawn
anyway I don't want to give up the
bishop only three maybe yeah maybe you
can play even that because Bishop h5
does F for coming now probably probably
I cannot really avoid it
hmm that's not really a good position
that's very unvarying secure everything
insecure oh the Sun didn't expect can
also take here yeah I know but this
isn't this isn't really great isn't it
would be as this would surprise me I
have a good piece coordination now venus
is dangerous here I bishop f7 maybe I
have f3 who are no he's retreating all
the way check check
Bishop g5 was my idea he's got he's got
f4 though but I have 94 then it's
probably okay oh how quickly okay I look
at five I haven't seen her look at five
well what do we had came again I don't
understand anything here
yeah it doesn't help i mean this was
very good for wider with with the Queen
on h5 does this whole operation was was
very strange but ok that blunder pieces
that it's all fine
time warning check rooks is so nice not
is not much but at least the check check
check check check check Jim just two
pawns check
it's got the wrong bishop but I don't
know it shouldn't be enough but I don't
exchange now I probably get mated
somehow like lasagna come on ah this is
I always always hated him replace him
some silly mafia and then give it away I
was of course Bishop c4 was relying on
this Bishop t5 move I don't think we r
plus 3 year not another not any surprise
he was directly going for this just
giving me all the good pieces check but
of course this is just even this is good
I only need to take on ahead mmm twin
cakes and nine and five that's also
winning for white yeah Knight g4 is just
blundering a piece yeah then you can
play all kinds of nonsense and win if
the opponent blunders pieces check jim t
i was just fishing check maybe there was
something but I don't know how much it
does not look like it check check check
yeah that's just no no way to save it
especially with this big space advantage
yeah the easiest is instead of her
Bishop c4 is to go here and just the
tech f5 after that you really has some
has no decent move note that this is
channel answered with this and this is
very easily winning
and look somebody these pieces are
totally silly check yeah and oops the
only move that you can play without
losing very immediate is this and here
this is also totally over I mean he must
exchange now and just compare the two
nights + + 4 yeah the computer is
obviously very merciless and this is
kind of position before it was very
unclear but the this playing this is
just just really a bit crazy because it
opens up back the whole position from my
pieces and this is leaving him with with
badly coordinated once i only check
overlooked i overlooked the rook at five
otherwise it's basically resign abble
okay thanks for watching